a moment for reflection and unity as
foreign ministers from the G20 stood for
a moment of silence to remember the
victims of the earthquakes in turkey and
Syria and it was in that spirit that
their host India's prime minister called
on those assembled to use the meeting
for resolution not Ranka
we should not allow issues
that we cannot resolve together
to come in the way
of those began
foreign Ministers of the world's 20
largest economies met in New Delhi the
war in Ukraine dominated discussions
along with its impact on Global Food
Supplies Energy prices and security
there are some matters of sharp
differences of opinions and views
yet
we must find common ground and provide
Direction because that is what the world
expects of us
on the sidelines a very brief meeting
between Russia's foreign minister Sergey
lavrov and U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken it was the first time
both have met since the Russian invasion
but if anything of substance was
achieved both remained tight-lipped
later at a press conference lavrov
blamed the failure for consensus on the
western Nations present
unfortunately the Declaration on behalf
of all Ministers of the G20 group was
not endorsed our Western colleagues like
a year ago under the Indonesian G20
Championship were seeking to bring to
the Forefront an issue with the
situation around Ukraine by truths and
untruths
and Anthony blinken conceded that the
failure to move forward threatened the
principles on which the G20 was founded
that there are real challenges to the
multilateral system and those challenges
in many ways are coming directly from
Russia which has been
violating the very principles that lie
at the heart of that system
India's chairmanship of the G20 was
supposed to be the blossoming of its
Ambitions to lead the global South
promoting issues like debt alleviation
and climate change but that seems to be
have put on hold by ongoing concerns
over the war in Ukraine pavni metal
al-jazeera New Delhi